this video is about how tech not
government
is your new ruler i was at a conference
last year at which a speaker
to the surprise of the audience started
discussing
the latest developments in female sex
tech
smart vibrators are now a thing
apparently
men too can have their fun and games
with oral sex simulators
both devices employ machine learning to
improve their service
this is data taken from the most
intimate areas of life
tech is finding applications in areas
and structures
never before thought of as tech smart
contact lenses will help you navigate
computer screens
and data will be extracted from
everything you see
microphones embedded in your molars will
help you communicate
and every word you say will be recorded
and processed you might be recommended a
cough suite if you're sounding croaky
or if you're sounding low you might be
recommended the services of a
psychologist
or somebody might try and sell you
something but your
appropriate speech could be monitored
too
a chip embedded in your hand will help
you pass through security barriers
to travel on public transport even to
make purchases
and data will be extracted from
everywhere you
go and everything you buy chips in other
parts of your body will monitor your
heartbeat breathing or your blood
pressure
data will be extracted and sent to your
doctor or insurer
where it will be compared with data from
other patients
there will be sensors in your clothes
tracking anything
from your temperature to your comfort
levels
you might even receive rewards for
wearing those clothes in certain
situations
there will even be neuro sensors
connected to your brain
which will extract data from your
thoughts
it's a trope of the detective thriller
that you learn about a suspect
from their rubbish smart bins will
monitor that as well
there will be sensors everywhere in your
house in your bed
your bathroom your kitchen and sitting
room
a robot companion with high artificial
emotional intelligence will keep you
company
it will take care of your cleaning admin
and home security too
as it does so everything will be
monitored
already your social media activity is
captured and recorded
your online searches which perhaps
reveal as much about you as
anything have already been captured
google keeps a record of all your
activity it knows
almost everything about you more
than any spiritual leader ever
gmail knows the emails which you draft
but do not send
that you thought but decided not to say
even your darkest fantasies acted out
in augmented or virtual reality will
have data
extracted from them there will not only
be centers on your person
but in your means of transport and at
your places of work
cities will have sensors of some kind
everywhere in both private
and public spaces in the lamps that like
the streets
the lights that guide the traffic and
the devices
which monitor the air everywhere you go
everything you say everything you do
asleep
or awake in the real world or the
virtual
even what you think will be scrutinized
in some way
every aspect of our lives will have some
kind of data extracted
the data is cleaned organized and
processed
into information which is then analyzed
and interpreted into knowledge
our lives will be uncovered and laid
bare even before those
to whom we have no accountability this
data will be used in a myriad of
different ways
to quantify you to influence you and to
control you
machines will constantly be sharing
information with each other
in the internet of things using faster
than ever 5g
systems by 2020 there were over 20
billion devices connected to the
internet by 2025
75 billion will be as machines learn
more and more not only will he be
scrutinized
but you will be increasingly quantified
and
ranked this will affect decisions about
the jobs you're offered
the loan deals you qualify for the price
of insurance you must pay
the level of service you're able to get
everything
will be rateable tech will make informed
predictions about you
when you're likely to die or become ill
how hard you're likely to work
how well you're likely to do a job how
successful
you're likely to be how faithful you're
likely to be yours
to your spouse how likely to you are to
commit a crime
how much money you're likely to earn and
whether
you're likely to go bankrupt or commit
tax fraud
accurate profiles can be built using
qualitative methods such as
psychographics platforms
will not necessarily treat people
equally those with the right qualities
will get better treatment than those
without
machine learning one company claims can
already predict if a person is a
criminal
with 90 accuracy using a single
photograph of their face it can predict
crime on the basis of circumstantial
evidence
the moral implications of predictive
probability in fighting crime
are considerable will people still be
presumed innocent
if the predictive data suggests
otherwise
your online reputation will be
everything
if you knew that every journey purchase
personal message
political utterance or act of rebellion
might be captured
and saved forever and then used to
determine your life chances
would you behave the same way
says tech writer jamie suskind when it
comes to guiding behavior
tech is superseding our laws and our
social
and moral codes the more you know about
someone
the easier it is to influence them
this all has a disciplinary side to it
with orwellian implications
china already closely monitors its 1.4
billion citizens
algorithms rank them on their behavior
issuing rewards or punishments where
appropriate
citizens act in certain ways to get
their score up
not all governments will go down this
route but we are still
beholden to the platforms which we use
we will be governed not so much by the
law of the land
but by the rules of the platform though
often
the two will inform each other the
ethical decisions which determine our
future
will be made less by elected politicians
theologians
or philosophers and more by those who
write
code take the driverless
car in the event of a crash do you hit
the pedestrians or drive into a wall
and risk your own life currently
you make such split-second decisions
yourself
the driverless car will have such
decisions embedded in its code
the moral machine project has conducted
an online survey of 40 million people
in over 200 countries to get an idea of
public preferences
it's generally agreed that cars should
aim to save
the largest number of lives prioritizing
the young
in some countries there is a preference
for saving women over the year
or in others law abiding pedestrians
over jaywalkers
in others decisions get more
controversial
the healthy are more favored than the
obese the exec
more favored than the homeless
how will such decisions be made by
parliamentary representatives
by coders or by public votes and surveys
if code is predicated on the latter as
seems most likely
again we see a traditional parliamentary
process
undermined by tech this is a major
change
to the way decisions are taken
code rather than law will determine what
you can
and cannot do currently the law works
as a deterrent if you commit this
offence you risk
that punishment be it a fine or
imprisonment
in future you will not be able to break
the law
because the code will not allow it you
will not be able to speed on the
motorway or park illegally
because the code in the vehicle will not
allow it
if a law enforcement officer flags you
down you will not be able to drive away
because your car will be programmed to
stop
you will not be able to skip fares on
the bus because automated payments will
be taken from your wallet
as soon as you get on fines too
will automatically be taken from your
wallet if you break the law
in some way the doctor will not be able
to proceed in a negligent manner
because the code in his equipment means
it will not function unless certain
protocols are followed
you will not be able to say
because there will be blocks which
prevent such utterances
or you will lose access to the platform
altogether
the reputational damage will affect your
possibilities going forward
digital technology will be increasingly
used as evidence
your whereabouts in any given moment
will be known so
will what you were doing a man in ohio
was recently found guilty of arson
because the readings from his pacemaker
were not consistent
with the increased heartbeat he would
have had if his story about waking up to
discover a fire
were true machines can already predict
the outcome of litigation
with greater accuracy than humans
ebay's digital dispute resolution
resolves around 60 million commercial
disagreements every year
that is three times the number of
disputes filed in u.s
courts surely it is inevitable that
similar systems will be
incorporated into the law to lighten the
load
of the west's overburdened courts
just as the written word and the
printing press changed the way the laws
of the land operated
so will code the language of the future
do the same tech will determine what you
see your perception and thus your
opinion
this might be the books or videos which
are suggested to you but there is a
darker side
tech already uses its own powerful
platforms to lobby and influence public
opinion
in favor of its own business interests
we saw that
in the lead-up to the us general
election in the way that facebook
twitter and youtube all know platformed
donald trump
google may not operate piracy sites but
its search engine
is the main means by which online piracy
sites are discovered
in 2012 it campaigned against the stop
online piracy act
and on the google home page it
encouraged users to vote against it
in just 24 hours 1.8 billion people saw
the message
tell congress don't censor the web
congressional representatives were
bombarded by campaigners
legislators were held captive and yet
rather hypocritically in the lead up to
the u s general election
we see all these sites very much acting
as sensors twitter facebook and youtube
can all
if it suits them no platform politicians
whose views they do not like you will
receive no
news or information about such
politicians
any news you do receive will be
unflattering
perhaps you go to hear that politician
speak live
ar filters could be used to make sure
you hear them in an
unflattering way it is well within
tech's power to do this
some suspect that is already happening
already
tech may be enabling us to do a thousand
things
we were not previously able to do and as
such
it is a tremendously liberating force
but it is also growing extraordinarily
powerful within society
and it is a tremendous threat to
individual liberty
and privacy as it betters government
systems
it could soon be more powerful if it
isn't already
the power dynamic in society has changed
the conflict is not so much tech versus
human
as humans who control tech versus those
that don't
this is the future we are heading into
large tech companies operate in the
interests of their management and owners
government at least in theory exists for
its people
yet here is the paradox the tech company
aims for market share
to get more users to do that it gives
the users the best possible service
the service people get from tech is
often better than that
which they receive from government from
health care
to transport to education to crime and
social order
tech is bettering state systems
in many cases tech is free the only tax
you must pay is your data
it's an example of the old adam smith
adage it is not
from the benevolence of the butcher the
brewer or the baker
that we expect our dinner but from their
regard to their own
self-interest perhaps tech
is the better governor the same
paradoxical incentive does not exist in
representative democracy
there is only the need to win enough
swing votes in elections every four or
five years
citizens cannot take their custom
elsewhere
around 40 of the vote is usually enough
to ensure victory
for now though talk of one replacing the
other
is premature they both need each other
tech
helps the government enforce its laws
collect its taxes
and grow its economies large tech
needs government for its legitimacy
the two are working together and allying
this is the emerging political balance
google has an 86 share of global
searches
there is a strong case for it to be
broken up the same goes for facebook
which has a 66 share of social media
neither will want that with the threat
of anti-trust and privacy regulation on
the horizon
google spent more on lobbying in the u.s
last year
than any other company no doubt such
logic was behind facebook's hiring of
former
uk deputy prime minister nick clegg to
be its head of global affairs
and communications twitter banned donald
trump
on the eve of the ascension of the new
biden administration
compliance is generally the way to stay
on site
google tends to comply with government
requests for information
the police do not need to scan gmail for
signs of child
pornography google does it for them
anytime such keywords are found google
automatically reports suspicious
activity
even if government doesn't do the
monitoring itself it can buy the data
from third
parties microsoft twitter
and youtube announced a combined
initiative
the global internet forum to counter
terrorism
following years of criticism that they
had failed
to block extremists on their platforms
twitter facebook apple youtuber and
spotify all acted within days of each
other
to ban the conspiracy theorist alex
jones and then
the uk political activist tommy robinson
met with a similar fate katie hopkins
donald trump all had huge followings
their followings were good for these
companies business
the decision to no platform was surely
taken
for political reasons but large tech
will not
always comply at least not publicly
after the san bernardino shooting where
14 people were killed and another 22
injured the fbi demanded apple's
assistance
in unlocking one of the killer's cell
phones
apple said it did not have the means to
do this
the fbi demanded apple write the
necessary code
to enable it to do so apple declined
the issue was taken to court in what
would be
because of the precedent it would set a
landmark case
the day before the hearing the fbi said
it had found a third party to assist in
unlocking the iphone
and obtained delay a week later the fbi
announced it had unlocked the phone
and the case was dropped what really
happened
all the while the companies which
control the technologies of power
grow in power these are the technologies
which
impact our ability to think speak and
travel
which impact the functioning of
democratic processes and social justices
if the crypto anarchists dream is
realized and large tech
is superseded by decentralized
autonomous organizations
then governments have a problem on their
hands
this day if it ever comes is still a way
away
for now big tech and the big state are
allied that was originally a chapter in
my book daylight robbery how tax
shaped our past and will change our
future which i ended up
and i'll be back with another video very
soon